I want to know Jason's thoughts on all of the successor languages that have been announced as, you know, one of the top, you know, we don't, we don't have I can't believe you would on October 26, 2022. My name is Connor, and today I finish my interview with Jason Turner as we talk about a couple of his most recent conference talks, all of the C++ successor projects, pattern matching, and more. Anything you want to say about the power of compile-time resources or the making C++ fun, safe, and accessible? Power of compile-time resources.
我想了解 Jason 对所有已经宣布的继承者语言的看法，你知道的，作为顶级语言之一，你知道的，我们没有，我们没有，我真不敢相信你会在 2022 年 10 月 26 日这样做。我是 Connor，今天我结束了对 Jason Turner 的访谈，我们聊了他最近的一些主题演讲、所有的 C++ 继承者项目、模式匹配等。关于编译期资源的威力，或者让 C++ 有趣、安全且易于使用，你有什么想说的吗？编译期资源的威力。
I kind of want to think of that one. No, wait a second. I have to think. What was the other talk that I gave this year? I don't remember what other i'm starting to think of the talk that i gave at cpp con um that was the 20 i think the one from a couple years ago or 2022 the con your new constexpr uh mental model i think that one that one might have been 2021 though oh yeah yeah yeah okay right right no no okay good i just had to put my my timeline in mental order here right so yes the power of compile time resources i actually enter that talk by saying this might
我有点想思考那一个。不，等一下。我得想想。我今年做的另一个演讲是什么？我不记得我另外……我开始想起我在 cpp con 上做的那个演讲了，呃，那是 20，我觉得是几年前的那个，或者是 2022 年的，那个关于你的新 constexpr 呃心智模型的演讲，我觉得那个，那个可能是 2021 年的吧，哦对，对，对，好吧，对，对，不，不，好吧，好，我只是需要在脑海中把时间线整理一下，对吧？所以，是的，编译期资源的威力，我其实在那个演讲的开场就说过，这可能
be the last talk that i give on constexpr and it's something like the 13th or something like that. If you look at like YouTube videos and conference talks and everything else, it's pretty high up there in number. But the point is, I think I've communicated everything I want to to convince people that you can move work to compile time. And there's several different ways to do that. And the more work you can move to compile time, the less runtime code you have. I mean, the obvious benefit is better performance at runtime, but then the side benefits that people don't think of like, well, code that doesn't execute at runtime is not open to vulnerabilities. It doesn't have undefined behavior. Like it can't, it's baked in. You have a data structure that you're accessing at runtime.
是我关于 constexpr 的最后一个演讲了，大概是第 13 个左右吧。如果你看看 YouTube 视频、会议演讲以及其他所有东西，它的数量确实排得相当靠前。但重点是，我觉得我已经传达了我想要传达的一切，以说服人们你可以将工作转移到编译期。有几种不同的方法可以做到这一点。你转移到编译期的工作越多，你的运行时代码就越少。我的意思是，显而易见的好处是更好的运行时性能，但还有人们不会想到的附带好处，比如，不在运行时执行的代码就不会受到漏洞的影响。它没有未定义行为。就像它不能那样，它是内联固化的。你有一个在运行时访问的数据结构。
It's literally the fastest, safest thing that you can possibly do because all of the limits and ranges and sizes of all the things are all known in the binary. And if you try to do something outside of those ranges and limits, in many cases, the compiler will binary. And if you try to do something outside of that, those ranges and limits, in many cases, the compiler will just stop you if you have your warnings turned on and tell you, uh, this is a stood array of, you know, string views of 10 or whatever. And you tried to access the 11th element. I'm just going to stop you right there because I know, because I was able to statically analyze the code, that that's a bad plan.
这绝对是你所能做的最快、最安全的事情，因为所有东西的限制、范围和大小都在二进制文件中全部已知。如果你试图做超出这些范围和限制的事情，在许多情况下，如果你开启了警告，编译器会把二进制文件……如果你试图做超出那些范围和限制的事情，在许多情况下，编译器会直接阻止你，如果你开启了警告，并且会告诉你，呃，这是一个 std::array，你知道的，包含 10 个 string_view 或类似的东西。而你试图访问第 11 个元素。我打算就在这里阻止你，因为我知道，由于我能够对代码进行静态分析，那是个糟糕的计划。
But what more could we want, right? Isn't there also, there's also the, I've heard this on Twitter in a talk that you can detect UB if you make it run at compile time, basically, because it's not allowed. Yeah, UB is not allowed at compile time. So anything, I would say pretty much any line of code being written that can be, that doesn't have to access runtime resources in some way, needs to be tested in a constexpr context because you need to know if it has that UB in it. Right. And it's, you know, the downside is
但我们还能想要什么呢？对吧？难道不还有，也有那个，我从 Twitter 上和一个演讲中听说，如果你让它在编译期运行，基本上就可以检测出未定义行为（UB），因为它是不被允许的。是的，未定义行为在编译期是不被允许的。所以任何事情，我会说几乎编写的每一行代码，只要是可以的、不需要以某种方式访问运行时资源的，都需要在一个 constexpr 上下文中进行测试，因为你需要知道它里面是否有那样的 UB。对。而且你知道，缺点是
you basically have to move all of your code to header files today because we don't have actual support from our compilers for modules. Yeah. Right, yeah. But, yeah, so that one was specifically about moving JSON resources into compile time data structures and just trying to get people to think about what compile time data structures can look like was the goal there.
你今天基本上必须将你所有的代码移到头文件中，因为我们没有从编译器获得对模块（modules）的实际支持。是的。对，是的。但是，是的，所以那个演讲专门关于将 JSON 资源移入编译期数据结构，其目标只是让人们思考编译期数据结构可以是什么样的。
So it was less like, look at these fancy tricks that you can pull and more like, look, just look at the end result and let's talk about that. And then my C++ on C talk, making C++ fun, safe, and accessible. It's partially a talk about making sure you're using proper tooling and setting up a correct environment. The more time I spent with this, I am a strong advocate of saying you, Connor, should be developing and, you know and not you specifically, but since you're the one I'm talking to, should be developing in an environment where while you're programming on your machine, all of the warnings should be enabled. Warnings should be enabled as errors.
所以与其说“看你能玩出这些花哨的把戏”，不如说“看，只看最终结果，让我们来谈谈这个”。然后是我的 C++ on Sea 演讲，主题是“让 C++ 有趣、安全且易于使用”。这部分是一个关于确保你使用适当的工具并建立正确环境的演讲。我花在这个上面的时间越多，我就越坚决地主张——你，Connor，应该在这样的环境中进行开发，你知道的，不是指你特指你自己，但既然你是我正在交谈的人，你就应该在这样的环境中开发：当你在机器上编程时，所有的警告都应该被启用。警告应该被启用为错误。
You should be having some clang-tidy analysis running in the background, like as you're typing. Most IDEs do this today anyhow. And then you need address sanitizer and UB sanitizer on your developer builds right now, because you're using the code in a way that shipped code isn't going to necessarily be used. We can't ship. You don't want to ship a binary with address sanitizer enabled. That's a bad plan. Like it's literally a bad plan. It increases the surface area of your project
你应该在后台运行一些 clang-tidy 分析，就像你在打字时那样。现在的绝大多数 IDE 无论如何都在这样做。然后你需要在你的开发版本中立即启用地址 sanitizer（AddressSanitizer）和 UB sanitizer，因为你使用代码的方式不一定是发布后的代码会使用的。我们不能发布。你不会想发布一个启用了地址 sanitizer 的二进制文件。那是个糟糕的计划。就像它真的是个糟糕的计划。它增加了你项目的攻击面，
and makes you more vulnerable to someone trying to hack your binary, security flaws, that kind of thing, because of all the instrumentation that address sanitizer has to do. But if you, while you're're developing have all these things enabled you're going to like immediately catch memory errors that might not find themselves until the code's been deployed on the client's site right so you need to have it enabled today while you're typing and so that was part of that that's like kind of the half of it is like how can we use the tools to teach people how to write C++? So part of the code is I put up a really bad example in Compiler Explorer.
并且由于地址 sanitizer 必须进行的所有插桩，让你更容易受到试图破解你的二进制文件的人的攻击，诸如安全漏洞之类的事情。但如果你在开发时启用了所有这些东西，你就会立即捕获到可能直到代码被部署到客户端现场时才会被发现的内存错误，所以你需要今天在打字时就启用它。这就是其中的一部分，这就像是其中一半的内容，比如我们如何使用这些工具来教人们如何编写 C++？所以代码的一部分是，我在 Compiler Explorer 中放了一个非常糟糕的例子。
And the compiler just tells you, like, you're missing this header file. Oh, you're right. You type in the header file. Oh, you're missing this. Oh, you're right. You do this. And then the compiler can tell you, well, it's an index past the end of the, oh, you're right.
然后编译器就会告诉你，比如，你漏掉了这个头文件。哦，你说的对。你输入了头文件。哦，你漏掉了这个。哦，你说的对。你做了这个。然后编译器可以告诉你，嗯，这是一个超出末尾的索引，哦，你说的对。
And you fix that. Oh, size mismatch, type mismatch. You fix that. Okay. And as you're working your way through, just doing what the compiler can tell you well it's an index past the end of the oh you're right and you fix that oh size mismatch type mismatch you fix that okay and as you're working your way through just doing it the compiler tells you to do then you get like an address sanitizer crash because you went off the end of the array and you're like oh well thanks address sanitizer for catching that for me and by the time we're done we don't have perfect code but just letting the tools walk us through what needed to be changed we had code that was considerably better when we were done. Yeah. The hard part,
然后你修复了它。哦，大小不匹配，类型不匹配。你修复了它。好的。当你一路走下去，只是照着编译器能告诉你的去做——“嗯，这是一个超出末尾的索引，哦，你说的对”，然后你修复了它；“哦，大小不匹配，类型不匹配”，你修复了它。好的。当你继续这样做，照着编译器叫你做的那样做，然后你就会得到类似地址 sanitizer 的崩溃，因为你越过了数组的边界，然后你会想，哦，谢谢地址 sanitizer 为我捕获了那个错误。等到我们完成时，我们并没有完美的代码，但仅仅是通过让工具引导我们完成需要更改的内容，我们最终拥有的代码要好得多。是的。困难的部分，
I think of all this or the hardest part is that this stuff doesn't come for free in terms of setting it all up, which I guess we can point people to your CPP starter project. Yeah. I really need to go back and like, you know, check issues that are open on that. I think I actually did try to use it once and then gave up because initially I didn't have something locally installed.
我觉得这一切，或者说最困难的部分是，就全部设置好而言，这些东西并不是免费得来的，我想我们可以把大家引向你的 CPP Starter Project。是的。我真的需要回过头来看看上面打开的那些 issues。我想我其实真的试用过一次，然后就放弃了，因为一开始我本地没有安装某个东西。
And then what I think I really wanted was the new Visual Studio. I think it's actually been around for a few years now. But they have a dinner menu, kind of like, check, check, check. What do you want here and you can you can check the things because over time i'm sure when you started cpp started project it was only had a few things but now it's basically like everything under the sun that you could possibly want and it's like as much as i might love all of this stuff it's like uh i'll just i just found some basically working project but then when it came time to set up clank tidy i think i mentioned this on my other podcast is that i just just, like, I stopped working on it.
然后我想我真正想要的是新的 Visual Studio。我觉得它其实已经存在好几年了。但他们有一个菜单，有点像勾选、勾选、勾选。你在这里想要什么，你可以勾选这些东西，因为随着时间的推移，我确信当你开始做 CPP Starter Project 时，它只有少数几样东西，但现在它基本上就像你可能想要的天下所有东西一样，这就像，尽管我可能非常喜欢所有这些东西，但它就像……呃，我还是找个基本上能用的项目吧。但当需要设置 Clang-Tidy 时，我想我在我的另一个播客里提到过，我只是……就，我停止了开发。
Because I was like, I'm at the point now where I've written several hundred lines of code, and I want to go clean things up. And so how do I go set up ClankTidy? Well, I've got to go download this Python file, and then I've got to hook that in with CMake. Now I've got to add CMake. And it's just, you know, whereas, yeah, other languages, that stuff kind of comes out of the box. And if we had some version of basically CPP starter project that you could, you know, on the command line, just like, you know, I think in Rust it's called Cargo or RustUp or Cargo New or whatever. I remember watching you and your cousin, John. JT.
因为我想，我已经到了这样一个阶段：我写了几百行代码，我想去清理一下。那么我该如何去设置 Clang-Tidy 呢？好吧，我得去下载这个 Python 文件，然后我得把它和 CMake 关联起来。现在我得添加 CMake。这简直是……你知道的，然而，是的，其他语言，那些东西开箱即用。如果我们有某种版本的 CPP Starter Project，你可以，你知道的，在命令行上，就像，你知道的，我想在 Rust 中它叫 Cargo 或 RustUp 或 Cargo New 之类的。我还记得看你和你的表弟 John。JT。
Yeah, JT. And then, like, I was typing alongside and i just cried inside of how easy like you guys got up and running and i got up and i was like they even like built a fake you know or a real like hello world file and tests are built in and i was just like this is this is heartbreaking as like a c++ you know someone who does it professionally and it's like where we need like and the community's been asking for it for you know in terms of um not so much build systems but like uh package managers and stuff and that story is is a is really missing from c++ and hopefully in the future we'll we'll have we'll
对，JT。然后，就像，我一边跟着敲代码一边在内心哭泣，你们上手是多么容易，而我上手的时候，我想，他们甚至还构建了一个假的，你知道的，或者一个真正的类似 Hello World 的文件，而且测试都是内置的，我当时就觉得，这太让人心碎了，作为一个 C++，你知道的，一个专业从事这方面工作的人，这就好像我们需要像……而且社区一直在求之不得，你知道的，就……呃，与其说是构建系统，不如说是包管理器之类的，而这个故事在 C++ 中真的是缺失的，希望在未来我们会有，我们会
have that story yeah it is definitely takes far more steps in c++ yeah but for now people can go watch the talk and go use your starter project yeah i think now we should we should get to what you know we talked about vaccines for a while and i'm sure there's a few listeners being like connor i don't care about vaccines i want to know that's true yes i want to know jason's thoughts on all of the successor languages that have been announced as, you know, one of the top, you know, we don't, we don't have. I can't believe you would bring this up, Connor. I refuse to talk about this.
有那样的故事。是的，在 C++ 中确实需要更多的步骤。是的。但现在人们可以去看演讲，去使用你的 Starter Project。是的，我想现在我们应该，我们应该聊聊你，你知道的，我们聊了一会儿疫苗，我确信有一些听众会觉得，Connor，我不在乎疫苗，我想知道——那是真的，是的，我想了解 Jason 对所有已经宣布的继承者语言的看法，你知道的，作为顶级语言之一，你知道的，我们没有，我们没有。我真不敢相信你会提起这个，Connor。我拒绝谈论这个。
You know, that's what's, you know, if, if it's, isn't it, there's a small part that's, you know, it's very sad that CppCast ended in general, but just that it ended right before all of this, I don't want to call it drama, but obviously it's been a hot topic on Hacker News and Reddit and there's Carbon from Google, there's CPP Front. We had Sean Baxter, who is the Circle individual. We had him on for an hour and a half that I think was three episodes and him talking about, you know, all his thoughts on Circle versus Cpp front versus carbon versus uh i guess cpp front and cpp2 are the same thing and then there's also jacked yeah or yacht is it yacht or jacked i think yacht i think is technically how it's supposed to be pronounced yeah i have no i've only heard of that i haven't you know seen anything on um andreas cling's uh streams or
你知道，那是怎样的，你知道的，如果，如果这不是，难道不是，有一小部分，你知道的，CppCast 的整体结束非常令人悲伤，但仅仅是因为它在所有这一切之前就结束了，我不想称之为戏剧性事件，但很明显它一直是 Hacker News 和 Reddit 上的热门话题，有来自 Google 的 Carbon，还有 CPP Front。我们邀请了 Sean Baxter，也就是那个制作 Circle 的个人。我们和他谈了一个半小时，我想那是三期节目，他谈到了，你知道的，他对 Circle 与 CPP Front 与 Carbon 的所有看法，呃，我猜 CPP front 和 cpp2 是一回事，然后还有 JACT，对，或者叫 Yacht？是叫 Yacht 还是 Jact？我觉得严格来说 Yacht 应该是那样的发音，对，我不知道，我只听说过，我没有，你知道的，在 Andreas Kling 的直播或者
anything like that uh anyways i'll turn it over to you. The C++ community, plus plus plus at large, has been wanting to hear what Rob and Jason, we're going to at least get to hear from Jason and Rob hopefully will get on in a later episode. Bait and switch. You didn't tell me we were going to be talking about this. I'm sure you have views though. I have some thoughts. What I'll say is of all the languages that you just mentioned, which ones can I actually use right now? So what do we mention? CPP? I mean, and you probably mean like in a context where you're doing something other than writing Hello World. Right. I don't think any. Actually, I don't know about JACT or Yacht.
诸如此类的地方看过任何东西……不管怎样，我把话筒交给你。C++ 社区，广义上的 C++ 社区，一直很想听听 Rob 和 Jason 的看法，我们至少能听到 Jason 的声音，Rob 以后有机会也会在一期节目中登场。调包计。你没有告诉我们要聊这个。不过我确信你有看法。我有某种想法。我要说的是，在你刚刚提到的所有语言中，我现在实际上能用哪一个？所以我们提到了什么？CPP？我的意思是，你可能指的是在做一些除了写 Hello World 之外的事情的语境下。对。我觉得没有。实际上，我不知道 JACT 或 Yacht。
Yacht is actually slowly replacing the C++ code in in serenity os yeah yeah so well i mean i don't know to what extent but that has a huge community around it for a for a startup language for an actual legit like uh um what's the word i'm looking for? Grassroots project. Has a lot of people working with it. That you can use right now. JT, my cousin, has almost completed their, I'm thinking at least sixth NES emulator written entirely in Yoct.
Yacht 实际上正在慢慢取代 SerenityOS 中的 C++ 代码。是的，是的。所以，嗯，我不知道到什么程度，但对于一门初创语言来说，它周围有一个巨大的社区，对于一门真正的、合法的……呃，我用什么词好呢？草根项目。有很多人在用它开发。你现在就可以使用它。JT，我的表弟，几乎已经完成了他们的，我估计至少是第六个完全用 Yoct 编写的 NES 模拟器。
Okay. Not the sixth written entirely in Yoct, but their sixth. This one happens the sixth written entirely in yacht, but their sixth, this one happens to be written in yacht. So one of JT's hobbies is to write an NES simulator and whatever language they're learning today. So that could be rust, C, Rust, and Yoct. Definitely at least those four. And I know this because I wrote a blog. Actually, I started my blog, the Code Report blog, specifically just so I could write a blog post about having JT or of the episode that you had with JT on CppCast because it was, from a programming language enthusiast point of view,
好吧。不是第六个完全用 Yoct 编写的，而是他们的第六个。这个恰好是第六个完全用 Yacht 编写的，而是他们的第六个，这个恰好是用 Yacht 编写的。所以 JT 的爱好之一就是用他们当下的新语言编写一个 NES 模拟器。所以那可能是 Rust、C、Rust 和 Yacht。绝对至少有这四种。我知道这一点是因为我写了一篇博客。实际上，我创办我的博客 The Code Report 博客，专门就是为了写一篇关于拥有 JT 的博客文章，或者关于你在 CppCast 上与 JT 那期节目的博客文章，因为从一个编程语言爱好者的角度来看，
absolutely awesome. JT has a ton of background with different projects and different programming languages. He's worked at Microsoft with TypeScript and Rust. He has worked on a programming language called Chapel. I think he also went to the University of Colorado? Boulder, yes, for a master's degree. Yeah, and I think worked, I could be getting this part wrong, but like on the LLVM or Clang
绝对太棒了。JT 在不同的项目和不同的编程语言方面有大量的背景。他曾在微软从事 TypeScript 和 Rust 的工作。他曾参与过一门名为 Chapel 的编程语言的工作。我想他还去过科罗拉多大学？博尔德分校，是的，攻读硕士学位。是的，而且我认为他还参与了，我这部分可能记错了，比如 LLVM 或 Clang
stuff there, potentially had some exposure to Chris Lager. The LLVM and Clang stuff was potentially had some exposure to chris the llvm clang stuff was during a short internship at apple okay yeah but uh jt's advisor at boulder was um oh shoot i can never remember his name when i want to remember it jeremy jeremy jeremy seek yeah was jt's advisor in boulder so that then is directly related to the TypeScript work. And then Jeremy's continued to do things like gradually typed Python and stuff since then. So yes, JT has had lots of exposure to programming languages and has created at least from scratch, helped me with ChaiScript. Started Rai. Are you familiar with ChaiScript, started Rai.
方面的工作，可能接触过 Chris Lattner。LLVM 和 Clang 的工作，是可能在苹果公司进行了一次短暂的实习期间接触到的。好吧，是的，但是 JT 在博尔德的导师是……哦，该死，每当我想记住他的名字时总是记不起来。Jeremy，Jeremy，Jeremy Siek，是的，这就是 JT 在博尔德的导师。所以这与 TypeScript 的工作直接相关。从那以后，Jeremy 继续做诸如渐进式类型化 Python 之类的事情。所以，是的，JT 接触过大量的编程语言，并且从零开始创建了，或者帮我搞过 ChaiScript。启动了 Rai。你熟悉 ChaiScript 吗，启动了 Rai。
Are you familiar with Rai? I thought it was RaiScript or is it just Rai? Or is it RaiScript? It might be RaiScript. It was influenced by Chai. Which was influenced by ChaiScript. But that took on a life of its own. Like JT like left the GitHub project up and walked away.
你熟悉 Rai 吗？我以为是 RaiScript，还是只是 Rai？或者它是 RaiScript？它可能是 RaiScript。它受 Chai 的影响。而 ChaiScript 又受其影响。但那有了它自己的生命。就像 JT 把 GitHub 项目留在那儿然后走开了一样。
And now there's like an organization around it people are still working on it and then a little toy language that didn't get very far called minnow and then yacht and yeah lots of programming languages i will link the blog post in the show notes but they have also been on a ton of different podcasts other than CPP cast, including a bunch of rust podcasts. And he was rusty spike, right? No. Yeah, very sad that those aren't you can't actually access them anymore. So I've been slowly listening through all the existing rust podcast episodes. I've gotten through a couple podcasts, but that's not saying much because there's only like eight episodes. But Rusty Spike aren't hosted anymore. But it's not the end of the world.
现在周围有一个组织，人们仍在对其进行开发，还有一个没有走太远的玩具语言叫 Minnow，然后是 Yacht，是的，有很多编程语言。我会在节目说明中附上这篇博客文章，但除了 CppCast 之外，他们还上过大量的其他播客，包括一堆 Rust 播客。他曾是 Rusty Spike 的主持人，对吧？不是。是的，非常遗憾那些已经……你实际上再也无法访问它们了。所以我一直在慢慢听完所有现有的 Rust 播客剧集。我已经听完了几个播客，但这说明不了什么，因为总共只有大约八集。但 Rusty Spike 已经不再托管了。不过这也不是世界末日。
I mean, it is what it is. And they had a Twitch stream, I think, if I'm not mistaken. And you were on that Twitch stream for a conversation, right? Yeah. So the Twitch channel, the live streaming was interviewing people who were just it was like live interviews kind of like this kind of thing and i was one of them and then uh andreas cling was one of them as well which i think is around the start of their collaboration or i could have the timing off interesting so anyway it's very very cool that you have a cousin
我的意思是，事情就是这样。而且他们还有一个 Twitch 直播，我想，如果我没记错的话。你曾在那次 Twitch 直播中进行过对话，对吧？是的。所以 Twitch 频道，直播是采访那些刚刚……这就像是现场采访，有点像这种东西，我是其中之一，然后……呃，Andreas Kling 也是其中之一，我想那是他们开始合作的时候，或者我的时间记错了。有趣的是，无论如何，很高兴你有一个表弟
that's sort of in rust land at the moment and you're in c++ land and um it's a very cool cool whatever artifact of the pl pl communities at large you should uh definitely have andreas and jt on here to talk about yacht oh yeah yeah well definitely um i mean having jt on would be uh yeah i mean we probably talked for for hours we'd have we'd have a hard time i'd have to have bryce there to to reign it in um but yeah andreas his interview that you had with him on cpp cast i thought was a phenomenal and also his just personal backstory is um incredibly interesting and kind of inspiring as well um so yeah we'll we'll definitely put them on the list of list of folks but yes back to the hot takes from jason that we
目前身处 Rust 领域，而你在 C++ 领域，这是 PL（编程语言）社区的一个非常酷的、非常酷的产物。你绝对应该请 Andreas 和 JT 到这里来聊聊 Yacht。哦，是的，是的，当然……我的意思是，请 JT 来会是……是的，我的意思是，我们可能会聊上几个小时，我们会很难收场，我得让 Bryce 在场来控制一下局面。但是，是的，你在 CppCast 上对 Andreas 的采访，我认为非常精彩，而且他个人的背景故事也……极其有趣，并且也有点鼓舞人心。所以，是的，我们绝对会把他们列入嘉宾名单。不过，言归正传，回到 Jason 的犀利观点，我们
were about to get that i went on a tangent uh so yacht is the only one that you can the act is the only one well no that's not true circle you could use and deploy in real code oh yeah that's a full working compiler yes no um nothing personal at all to uh to uh shoot what's his name again brain cramp uh chandler no no the one who was circle uh sean oh sean baxter yes sorry um no i think the fact that circle is a closed source compiler without a company behind it was slow its adoption in a lot of places. And Carbon, as far as I know, still doesn't actually have anything to look at. I'm like, okay, fine, I'll play with the Carbon compiler. Oh, no, wait, there isn't a Carbon compiler. Never mind, I won't play with it.
刚才差点就听到了，我扯远了……所以 Yacht 是唯一一个你可以……Act 是唯一一个……好吧，不，这不是真的，Circle 你可以真正在实际代码中使用和部署。哦，是的，那是一个功能完整的编译器。是的，不……对……呃……完全没有针对……呃……呃……怎么称呼他来着？脑子短路了……Chandler？不，不，那个制作 Circle 的人……Sean？哦，Sean Baxter，对，抱歉……不，我认为 Circle 是一个没有公司支持的闭源编译器，这减慢了它在许多地方的普及速度。至于 Carbon，据我所知，实际上仍然没有什么可看的。我就想，好吧，去吧，我去玩玩 Carbon 编译器。哦，不，等等，根本没有 Carbon 编译器。算了，我不玩了。
It's just a lightweight interpreter at the moment. And then that we had cpp front yeah cpp front which interesting i don't know i still need to watch herb's keynote on that i it's it's literally a tab open on my laptop right now i haven't hit play yet i need to do that um and then there's the one from types what's it called types values values that's what it's oh val yeah val out of it's kind of out of adobe but it's mostly out of dave abraham's who formerly worked on swift and formerly worked on c++ so i think the the basic i'm not going to give any personal strong opinion here. What I'm going to say is I don't really see anything yet. Like when these languages exist, we can have another
它目前只是一个轻量级解释器。然后我们有了 CPP Front，是的，CPP Front，有趣的是，我仍然需要观看 Herb 在那上面的主题演讲。它……它实际上是我笔记本电脑上开的一个标签页，我还没点播放，我需要去看一下。然后还有来自 Type……叫什么来着？Types Values，对，就是那个。哦，Val。Val 有点像来自 Adobe，但它主要来自 Dave Abrahams，他曾效力于 Swift 团队，也曾效力于 C++ 团队。所以我想，基本上……我在这里不会发表任何强烈的个人意见。
conversation. But then I will say from having my pulse, my finger still on the pulse of the C++ community, even though I'm not hosting a podcast anymore. The general response on Twitter and Reddit seems to be, I just want a safer C++. Why do you all keep changing the syntax? That's the feels that I get. They don't want a new syntax. They don't want a new syntax. Well, so when you say, why do you keep changing the syntax? Does that mean like with respect to Carbon and CPP front, which is kind of they're having
我要说的是，我暂时还没看到任何东西。就像当这些语言真正存在时，我们可以进行另一场对话。但我会说，凭借我对 C++ 社区脉搏的持续关注（尽管我不再主持播客了），Twitter 和 Reddit 上的普遍反应似乎是：“我只想要一个更安全的 C++。你们为什么总是在改变语法？”这就是我的直觉感受。他们不想要新语法。他们不想要新语法。嗯，所以当你问“你们为什么总是在改变语法？”时，这是否意味着就 Carbon 和 CPP Front 而言，它们有点像拥有
all this backward compat, but they're saying, no, no, no, we want to still live in C++. We don't want to switch to a new thing, whether that's a language or a front end or whatever you want to call CPP2. They just want a safer version of what they're currently working with. Virtually every average C++ like the you know the the person who's out there just getting work done that i have any conversation with or read their twitter comments or the reddit comments about this they want the ability to just like put a pragma at the top of the c++ file saying well these things aren't allowed. We're now using the newer version of whatever, right?
所有这些向后兼容性，但他们说，不，不，不，我们仍然想生活在 C++ 中。我们不想转向新事物，不管是语言、前端，还是你管 CPP2 叫什么。他们只想要他们当前正在使用的东西的安全版本。几乎每一个普通的 C++ 开发者——就像那些在外面埋头苦干、我与之交流过或者阅读过他们推特评论或红迪（Reddit）评论的人——他们都想要这样一种能力：只需在 C++ 文件的顶部放一个 pragma，说“这些东西是不被允许的。我们现在使用的是某个版本的更新版本，对吧？”
They just want to be able to like turn off old features that they are deemed dangerous or whatever, like point arithmetic disallowed, whatever, right? They don't want a brand new programming language. They want a simpler, safer C++ to fall out like pragma disable the pre-processor i don't know you know something like that that's actually very close to what sean baxter his i mean he's at a bunch of stuff yeah yeah so circle is the outlier here right because circle is c++ plus plus plus C++++++. And he said basically that he doesn't want, you know, he thinks that any future vision, because there's all these visions attached to Carbon and attached to CPP front is like, we are C++. We have a committee.
他们只是希望能够关闭那些被认为危险的旧特性或诸如此类的事情，比如不允许指针算术等等，对吧？他们不想要一门全新的编程语言。他们想要一个更简单、更安全的 C++ 演化版本，比如 pragma 禁用预处理器，我不知道，你知道，类似的东西。这实际上非常接近 Sean Baxter 的……我的意思是，他做了很多事情，对吧，对，所以 Circle 是这里的特例，对吧？因为 Circle 就是 C++ 加上加加加加加。他说过基本上他不想，你知道的，他认为任何未来的愿景——因为有所有这些附属于 Carbon 和 CPP Front 的愿景，比如“我们就是 C++。我们有一个委员会。
We make design changes, whatever. We add new things to language library. Like we can materialize whatever future we want to materialize. We just, as a community have to decide that that's what we want. And his sort of take was that he doesn't think that we need to switch to, you know, a whole new, you know, Google will do what Google does, as he mentioned, like Google is basically an entire country, you know, if they're going to create a language, they can immediately be successful just if they're using it at Google because they have so many
我们做出设计变更，诸如此类。我们为语言库添加新东西。就像我们可以实现我们想要实现的任何未来一样。我们只是作为一个社区，必须决定这就是我们想要的。”他的看法大致是，他认为我们不需要转向一门全新的，你知道的，Google 会做 Google 会做的事，正如他所提到的，Google 基本上是一个完整的国家，你知道的，如果他们要创造一门语言，他们只要在 Google 内部使用它就能立即取得成功，因为他们有那么多的
engineers. And so like, you know, Google can do whatever Google does, although they're not aiming it to be just a Google project. So we'll see where it goes. But he basically said is like, whatever we want as a community, we should just work towards making that happen inside of C++. We have the power to do that. The question is just like, are we as a community going to make that happen the other question is does the the iso model like prohibit major changes happening i have no opinion on that i've never been to a committee meeting i've never submitted a paper it's a slight lie i've had my name on a couple of papers but i didn't write them i thought you had been, I recall you saying that you went to Kona. I did. But you never went to the meeting? I went to Kona in 2021, bought my plane tickets and everything,
工程师。所以，你知道的，Google 可以做 Google 所做的事，尽管他们的目标并非仅仅成为一个 Google 项目。所以我们将拭目以待它会走向何方。但他基本上是说，无论我们作为社区想要什么，我们都应该致力于在 C++ 内部实现它。我们有能力做到这一点。问题仅仅在于，我们作为一个社区是否会去实现它？另一个问题是，ISO 模型是否禁止重大变更的发生？我对此没有意见。我从未参加过委员会会议。我从未提交过论文。这有点撒谎，我的名字曾出现在几篇论文上，但我并没有写它们。我以为你参加过，我记得你说过你去过科纳。我去过。但你从来没去过会议？我在 2021 年去了科纳，买好了机票和所有东西，
flew to Hawaii. So you were planning on going to a committee meeting? I was planning to go to a committee meeting, yes. Had the world not stopped. Yes, but it's fine. I got a lovely vacation to Hawaii with my wife. Interesting, interesting. So my memory does serve correctly. It's just that committee meeting that you had planned to go to never ended up happening. Correct. So now I can still say I'm an outsider when it comes to this. Yeah. And I should have expected that would have been your general response is like,
飞往了夏威夷。所以你当时是计划去参加委员会会议的？我当时确实计划去参加委员会会议，是的。如果世界没有按下暂停键的话。是的，但没关系。我和妻子在夏威夷度过了一个美好的假期。有趣，有趣。所以我的记忆确实没有出错。只是你原本计划去的那场委员会会议最终没有发生。没错。所以我现在仍然可以说，当涉及到这一点时，我是一个局外人。是的。我本该预料到这会是你的普遍反应，就像是，
I'll have an opinion when I can use things. It's because that's typically been your take on all new C++ features is that you usually don't start poking around and making, you know, C++ weekly video until something has actually been added to the standard and you can actually play around with it in a compiler. Because otherwise, you know, you'll start looking at revision R3 of some paper and be like, oh, look what's neat, what's coming. And then you'll make a video about it. And then sure enough, half a year later, when it gets put in, they'll have, you know, drastically changed the feature.
“等我能使用这些东西时，我会发表意见的。”那是因为这通常是你对所有新 C++ 特性的态度，你通常不会开始摸索并制作（你知道的）C++ Weekly 视频，直到某个特性真正被加入到标准中，并且你可以在编译器中实际玩转它。因为否则，你知道的，你会开始查看某个论文的 R3 修订版，然后说：“哦，看看有什么酷炫的，要来了。”然后你会做一个视频。果不其然，半年后，当它被放进去时，他们会，你知道的，对这个特性进行大幅度的更改。
And your take has always been, you know, what value am I giving if I'm covering some future feature that is not actually concretized yet? Because I'm just going to be not misinforming. You'll be informing at some temporary state of some feature. It's probably about three years ago. I pretty much made it a hard and fast rule that I'm not going to cover something unless I can demo it in a live compiler today. Yeah. You probably save quite a bit of time making that like a hard and fast rule for yourself because a lot of podcast drama is like, oh, we got to talk about this feature that's going to
而你的态度一直是，你知道的，“如果我报道某个尚未真正具象化的未来特性，我能提供什么价值呢？”因为你只是不会……不是传达错误信息。你是在传达某个特性的某个临时状态。大约是三年前吧。我几乎给自己定下了一个铁律：除非我今天能在实时编译器中演示它，否则我绝不报道任何东西。是的。为自己制定这样一个铁律，你大概节省了相当多的时间，因为许多播客的戏剧性事件都在于：“哦，我们得谈谈这个要经历七次修订、需要花十年或两个周期才能被纳入的特性。”而你的版本是，你只是等到它真正敲定。而且我也认为我节省了大量的脑力，因为我从来不用去想：“等等，那是论文版本里的，还是发布版本里的，或者什么的？”不，完全不用担心那个。
go through seven revisions and it'll take, you know, a decade or two cycles to get in. Whereas your version, you just wait until it's actually finalized. And I also think I save a lot of mental capacity because I never have to say, wait, was that in the paper version or was that in the released version or whatever? No, don't have to worry about that. Yeah. Yeah. Literally. Was it last episode?
是的。真的。是上一期节目吗？
I was asking Bryce because he just gave a talk. And one of the he was focused on top three things to look forward to. And one of them he was focused on top three things to look forward to and one of them was pattern matching and i had sort of forgotten about pattern matching because at one point it was supposed to be in 23 and then i asked him oh yeah like what's the status of that like uh there was michael park's proposal and friends you know he's one of the names on it but there's a bunch of folks that have worked on it but then there's also the is as proposal that came so like there's two competing proposals and i actually don't know what then.
我问 Bryce 是因为他刚刚做了一个演讲。其中的一个……他专注于“最值得期待的三件事”，而其中的一个……他专注于“最值得期待的三件事”，其中之一就是模式匹配，而我有点把模式匹配这事给忘了，因为有一段时间它本该在 C++23 中推出，然后我问他：“哦，对了，那东西现在进展如何了？”呃，有 Michael Park 的提案以及各位（你知道的，他是署名人之一），但还有一帮人也参与其中。不过，还有 is-as 提案的出现，所以，比如有两个相互竞争的提案，而我实际上不知道接下来会怎样。
So it's like you're saying, you have to keep track of there's not necessarily just one proposal for a certain feature. There's competing proposals. Well, at some point, those merge, et cetera. It does take up a lot of bandwidth to keep track of that stuff. I will give an opinion there. I am not a fan of is-as. I think it'll make the language harder to teach.
所以这就像你说的，你必须跟踪……某个特定特性不一定只有一个提案，而是有多个相互竞争的提案。好吧，在某个时候，这些提案会合并等等。跟踪这些东西确实需要消耗大量的带宽。我可以在这里发表一个意见。我不喜欢 is-as。我认为这会使这门语言更难教。
Really? Yes. And I think in many ways it comes right back around to my recent rant about implicit conversions because it's hiding conversions from you. If you say I want this as this thing, it might be a dynamic cast, it might be a static cast, it might be a reinterpret cast. I don't know. I'll give it to you sure like doesn't sound good to me sounds yeah that's a great point and that's exactly against best
真的吗？是的。而且我认为在许多方面，这又直接回到了我最近关于隐式转换的咆哮，因为它把转换对你隐藏了。如果你说“我想把这个作为（as）这个东西”，它可能是一个 dynamic_cast、一个 static_cast，也可能是一个 reinterpret_cast。我不知道。我把它交给你，当然……听起来对我不太好，听起来……是的，这真是一个极好的观点，这完全违背了保持显式这一最佳实践，我们应该编写不需要强制转换的代码，而不是编写一堆有趣的隐式转换给我们添乱的代码。是的。另外，我也一直很好奇，实际上，我好久没完整阅读过那篇论文了，我只是粗略浏览了一下……比如，is 和 as 的地盘争夺战是怎样的？甚至可能吗？它可能在模式匹配结构内部是上下文敏感的。
practice of being explicit about that we should write code that doesn't need cast not code that has a bunch of fun implicit cast for us yeah also too i've always wondered i'm actually it's been a while since i've never read that paper fully i just perused it but uh like what what is the land grab of is an ass like is that even it might be contact sensitive inside of the pattern matching construct okay so yeah it's you can still have you know is or as as a variable name elsewhere and it's fine i just actually reviewed these two different papers like last week because i am preparing an episode where i'm going to talk about features that i want
哦，是的，你仍然可以在其他地方将 is 或 as 用作变量名，这没问题。我上周刚刚审阅了这两篇不同的论文，因为我正在准备一期节目，打算谈谈我希望在 C++ 中看到的即将推出的特性，所以我不得不回头查看当前的论文列表。就像你说的，那两个不同的相互竞争的论文，其中一篇里面有 is 和 as，而另一篇没有。个人而言，我觉得没有的那篇语法的可读性要高得多。有趣。我们能先睹为快这个分条列出的特性清单吗，还是人们必须等待？他们得去订阅这个频道。我得翻翻我的笔记，但模式匹配，我认为它在上面排得很靠前，因为我认为模式匹配是少数几件会改变日常 C++ 开发者（不是库编写者，而是日常 C++ 用户）使用这门语言的方式的事情之一。我想我的意见确实改变过几次。我想要反射，但我从未将其视为标准委员会和我的个人愿望清单上的首要任务，
coming up in c++ so i had to go back and look at the current paper list and that yeah like you said the two different competing papers there's one that has isn't as in it and there's one that doesn't and the one that doesn't i think has a much more readable syntax, personally. Interesting. Can we get a preview of the itemized list of features, or do people have to wait? They got to go subscribe to the channel. I would have to pull up my notes, but pattern matching is, I think, strong on there, because I think pattern matching is one of the few things that will change the way the everyday C++, not the library writer, but the everyday C++ user will use the language. I do think I've changed my opinion a few times. I want reflection, but I was never considering it to be a priority for the standards committee and my personal
因为那是我想用的东西。但它会让这门语言变得更容易还是更难教？它会成为我，你知道的，C++ 应用程序开发者会使用的东西吗？我决定，是的，最终是的，如果我们想要反射的话，哪怕只是为了能够真正枚举一个枚举（enum）中的所有值，也是如此。哪怕只是为了这个。是的，我的意思是，有一堆用于做这种事情的宏（macro）黑客手段，特别是当你来自其他语言——在那里这只是一个你唾手可得的实用工具——时，你在 C++ 中为了实现这一点而不得不跳过的圈套，真是太疯狂了。这些是主要的两个东西，然后我会说我想要的下一件事是真正从语言中移除隐式转换，
cue because that's something I want. But is it going to make the language easier or harder to teach? Is it going to be something that I will, you know, the, the C++ applications developer is going to use? And I decided, yeah, ultimately, yes, we do want reflection if for no other reason than to be able to actually enumerate the values in an enumeration if for no other reason yeah i mean there's a bunch of libraries macro you know hacks for doing that kind of thing and especially coming from other languages where that's just a utility you can reach for it's yeah it's crazy the hoops you have to jump through in c++ to make that happen those are the main two things and then i would say the next thing that i want is to actually remove implicit conversions from the language,
我知道这不会发生。但我的意思是，永远别说绝无可能。我个人的看法是，C++ 现在正处于这样一个人生的拐点，所有这些项目、语言，随便你怎么称呼它们，都在涌现，C++ 不得不对此做出某种反应。这对 C++ 来说不一定是件坏事。这，你知道，我想，甚至我不记得……我要把是谁说这话的人记混了，是 Chandler，或者是参与这些项目之一的其他人，他们提到，你知道，一种可能性是，你知道，
which I know is not going to happen. But I mean, never say never there. My personal take is that C++ is at this kind of inflection point right now, and that there's all these projects, languages, whatever you want to call them popping up. And C++ is going to have to react to this somehow. This isn't necessarily a bad thing for C++. This, you know, I think, you know, even I can't remember, I'm going to mess up who said this, it was Chandler, or someone else who's working on one of these projects where like, you know, a possibility is that, you know,
我们对这些事情进行实验。但归根结底，它最终只会改进 C++。这仍然被认为是一场胜利，对吧？因为归根结底，它最终只会改进 C++。这仍然被认为是一场胜利，因为归根结底，许多这类项目的动机都是无法做出，你知道的，向后……你知道的，改动、向后兼容性、破坏性变更。并且，你知道，他们在布拉格开会时，他们说，你知道，对做出改动说“不”。但我不知道，我觉得在下一个十年里会发生一些事情，使之成为可能，如果这是一种 30 年或 50 年一遇的事情，或者，你知道，也许他们重新引入了类似于……呃，Rust 的 Edition（版本）那样的东西，Vittorio Romeo 有过关于 Epoch（纪元）的那个提案，
we experiment with these things. But at the end of the day, it just ends up improving C++. And that's still considered like a win, right? Because at the end of the day, it just ends up improving C++. And that's still considered like a win, because at the end of the day, a lot of these projects are motivated by not being able to make, you know, backwards, you know, changes, backwards compatibility, breaking changes. And, you know, we they had the meeting in Prague, where they said, you know, no to making changes. But I don't know, I think something in the next decade is going to happen that enables it either if it's like a once in 30 years or 50 years kind of thing or you know maybe they reintroduce something like um rust's uh additions you know vittorio romeo had that proposal for epochs yeah i think something like that is going to have to happen you know something is going to change i
是的，我觉得必须发生类似的事情，你知道，总会有所改变，我不知道那会是什么，但我觉得有一种可能性，就像请求一样，把那个关掉，你知道的，这将会成为可能。Sean 当时在谈论，你知道，有一种方法，而且是 Sean Baxter，不是 Sean Parent，有一种方法可以，逐个文件地，你知道的，开启某些特性。就像我们可以用 pragma 语句做到这一点一样，当然它会造成每个文件的不同风格的激增。但就像，你知道的，你可以做到这一点，进行测试，然后在某个时候朝着……Haskell 所做的事情努力，在那里他们有许多这样的扩展。然后在 20 或 30 年里破天荒地第一次，他们基本上说：“看，这是一组基本上每个人都在开启的扩展，或者是一大批使用 Haskell 的人都在开启的扩展。让我们直接把它们加入到 Haskell 2021 或他们管它叫什么里面去。”
don't know what it is but like i feel like there's a chance that like requests, like turning that off, you know, it's, it's going to be a possibility. Sean was talking about, you know, there is a way to, and the Sean Baxter, not Sean Parent, there is a way to, you know, by file by file, like turn on certain features. Like we can do that with, you know, pragma statements and sure it creates, um, a proliferation of different styles per file. But like, you know, you can do that, test them out, and then at some point work towards, you know, what Haskell did, where they have a bunch of these extensions. And then for the first time in 20 or 30 years, they basically said, you know, here's a set of extensions that basically everyone's turning on or like a huge subset of folks that use Haskell are turning on. Let's just add them to Haskell 2021 or whatever they called it.
所以现在那些扩展，你知道的，开箱即用。你不必去特地开启它们。我不会说“永远别说绝无可能”。你或许能如愿以偿，特别是，我的意思是，你有 22,000 个粉丝。你知道，你拥有……哦，是的，我很强大。哦，抱歉。这是一个播客。
And so now those extensions, you know, ship out of the box. You don't have to go and turn them on. I wouldn't say never say never. You could get your wish, especially, I mean, you got 22,000 followers. You know, you got. Oh, yes, I am powerful. Oh, sorry. This is a podcast.
我刚刚对此翻了个白眼。澄清一下，我其实并不觉得自己在这个社区里很有权力。你在 YouTube 上有接近 10 万订阅者，你知道的，如果你想的话，你可以掀起一场运动。好吧，我打算不久后做一次直播，目标将是编写我自己的 Clang-Tidy 检查，将隐式转换作为 Clang-Tidy 检查禁用掉，只是为了看看会发生什么。我想看看它的余波，我想尝试一下。是的，我的意思是，还有另一个很棒的工具，我一直……我的意思是，我实际上看到过
I just rolled my eyes at that. To be clear, I do not actually consider myself to be powerful in the community here. You got close to 100 000 subscribers on youtube you know you could you could cause a movement if you if you want to do well i i want to do a live stream soon um and the goal is going to be to write my own cling tidy check that disables implicit conversions as a cling tidy check just to see what what happens i want to see the fallout of it i want to try it yeah i mean there's there's another great tool i've always i mean i saw actually i
我刚才听到这儿直翻白眼。坦白说，我其实并不觉得自己在这个社区里有多大影响力。你在YouTube上快有10万订阅者了，你知道的，如果你愿意的话，完全可以发起一场运动。好吧，我最近想做一次直播，嗯，目标是自己写一个clang-tidy检查器，用来禁用隐式转换，就当作一个clang-tidy检查，看看会发生什么。我想看看它会引发什么后果，我想试一试。是的，我是说，还有另一个很棒的工具，我一直——我是说，我其实看到过一个……
think in your talk it added const to the auto parameter in a range base for loop yeah and that's something i know that clang tidy for a long time was trying to add a the basically the equivalent in rust where it lets you know hey you've added a mute keyword you don't need that you haven't modified or mutated your your variable the opposite is for c++ is adding const whenever you can does did that get added in the range-based for loop because that clang tidy thing got added do you know or i think that got added in the range-based for loop just because of the modernized transformation, but I did observe cling tidy just a few days ago, the latest trunk saying, hey, you can add const here actually. And I think it was the first time I'd seen that outside of the context of a ranged for loop modernized transformation.
我想在你的演讲中，它给基于范围的for循环里的 auto 参数加上了 const，对吧？我知道 clang-tidy 很久以来一直试图添加基本上等同于 Rust 中的功能，即它会让你知道“嘿，你加了一个 mut 关键字，你其实不需要它，你并没有修改或变异你的变量”。C++ 的反面则是尽可能地添加 const。那个功能是因为 clang-tidy 的那个特性被加入，才被加到基于范围的for循环里的吗？你知道吗？或者我觉得那个被加到基于范围的for循环里只是因为现代化改造转换，但我几天前确实观察到 clang-tidy 的最新主干版本说：“嘿，你其实可以在这里加 const。”我想这是我第一次在基于范围的for循环现代化改造转换之外看到这一点。
I will have to go check that out. That's something I've wanted for, I mean, I went and tracked that issue for a while. Like it's been out there for two or three years because that's, that's one of the things you've talked about was the talk. C++ code smells. Yes. Yes. C++ code smells.
我得去看看。这是我一直想要的功能，我是说，我追踪那个问题有一段时间了。大概两三年了吧，因为那是……那是你谈过的事情之一，即演讲《C++ 代码异味》。是的。是的，《C++ 代码异味》。
Yeah. And I, I ended up giving a talk called my least favorite anti-pattern, which I acronymed ITM for initialize, then modify. And then I realized after I was referencing a few people's talks is that I hadn't watched fully C++ code smells. I had just stolen a couple of snippets. But then when I watched that talk, I was like, oh man, like this, I'm basically just giving Jason's talk, like with a different flavor and style. Cause at the end of it, I was basically like const driven development. You just add const to things and like, you're
对。我最后做了一个名为《我最讨厌的反模式》的演讲，我把它缩写为 ITM（初始化，然后修改）。后来我意识到，自我引用了几个人的演讲之后，我并没有完全看懂《C++ 代码异味》。我只是偷了几个片段。但当我看完那个演讲时，我想：“天哪，我基本上就是在做杰森的演讲，只是换了一种风格和语气。”因为在演讲结束时，我基本上是在说“const 驱动开发”。你只需给事物添加 const，然后你……
going to fix half of the issues of like initializing something and then modifying it you can just const trying program with const and then make const or default yeah yeah it's uh so yeah just go watch jason's video you don't have to bother watching mine i realized i basically given the same talk or prepared the same talk accidentally that you have done and even kate's given yeah similar talks in that vein it's not it's not a um one person came up with this definitely kate and james were the my some of my inspiration for that because they gave a talk that said just start at like take the first value add cons to it and see what breaks and figure out why and just do that just make everything const one line at a time yeah it's i mean it's so nice in rust
就会解决一半的问题，比如初始化某物然后修改它，你可以尝试用 const 编程，然后设为 const 或默认。对，对，所以……去看看杰森的视频吧，你不用费心看我的了。我意识到我基本上不小心做了和你一样的演讲，甚至凯特也做过……对，也有类似方向的演讲。这不是某一个人想出来的，凯特和詹姆斯绝对给了我一些灵感，因为他们做过一个演讲，说只需从……取第一个值，给它加 const，看看什么坏了，找出原因，然后就这样做——一次只给所有东西加一行的 const。对，我的意思是，这在 Rust 里太棒了……
um also i've mentioned probably rust more times in this recording than i have in like all the other episodes and that's just because i've been playing around with it on the side but yeah the the fact that it's built into it's the default in rust it's like most of the times i'm just writing code and i don't ever have to put mute there like everything is is declarative and const and also too kate and james refers to kate gregory and james mcnellis i believe uh just in case if we have people that aren't in aren't in the inner or haven't heard of kate kate and james but they i mean james i'm actually not sure if he has given any c++ talks recently i know he was a prolific speaker early
另外，我在这段录音中提到 Rust 的次数可能比我在其他所有剧集加起来还要多，这只是因为我在业余时间一直在捣鼓它。但事实是，它内置在其中——这是 Rust 的默认设置。就像大多数时候我写代码时，甚至根本不需要放 mut 一样，一切都是声明式的、const 的。还有，凯特和詹姆斯指的是凯特·格雷戈里（Kate Gregory）和詹姆斯·麦克内利斯（James McNellis），我想……以防我们有一些听众不在核心圈子里，或者没听说过凯特和詹姆斯。不过他们……我是说詹姆斯，我其实不确定他最近是否做过任何 C++ 演讲，我知道他早期是一位多产的演讲者……
earlier on a while no not since not since covid i guess would be my guesstimate not since 2020 i mean that sounds that sounds about right i'm thinking about like when we last had james on cbp cast whatever yeah i don't know i mean i'm not saying that there's anything to that i'm just thinking timeline wise i think 2019 was approximately the last time that i recall yeah yeah both both fantastic speakers i think they've even co given co-talks together where they were co-speakers well yeah that's the one that i'm referring to is where they were with the one where they say to just make things const and work your way down that was a talk they gave together all right well so i mean we've gone a while a few minutes past what i had this slotted for. Are there any other hot takes or things you've got?
早些时候有一段时间……没有，自从新冠疫情以来就没有了，我猜大概是这样。自从 2020 年以来就没有了。嗯，听起来差不多。我在想我们上次邀请詹姆斯上 CppCast 是什么时候，不管怎样……是的，我不知道，我是说我并不是说这有什么特别的，我只是从时间线推测，我认为 2019 年大约是我能记起的最后一次了。对，对，两位都是出色的演讲者，我想他们甚至还一起合作过演讲，作为共同演讲者。哦，对，我指的就是那个，他们说只要把事情设为 const 并逐步向下推进，那是他们共同做的演讲。好吧，所以……我的意思是，我们已经过了我原定安排的时间几分钟了。你还有什么热门观点或想分享的事情吗？
I don't have hot takes. No hot takes? Anything, any curious things that, you know, you've been wanting to tell the C++, not that our listeners are all C++ers, but, you know, the C++ community since not have, I guess you've got Twitter still. So if there's really something you can just, you can just tweet it, folks. I've made my opinions known and my Twitter follower count has improved for it. Apparently, Twitter likes hot takes. So yeah, it is a little unfortunate that, you know,
我没有什么热门观点。没有热门观点？有什么奇妙的事情，你知道的，你一直想告诉 C++ 社区的吗？倒不是说我们的听众全都是 C++ 程序员，但你知道，C++ 社区自从没有了……我想你大概还有 Twitter 吧。所以如果真有什么事，你完全可以发推特告诉大家。我已经表明了我的立场，我的 Twitter 粉丝数也因此上升了。显然，Twitter 喜欢热门观点。所以，是的，有点不幸的是……
the spice it's like, I'm not sure if you've heard about the chess drama. Yes, yes. But like the fact that, you know, it's not really a great thing. You don't want there to be more cheating and et cetera and all this stuff. But like it really seems like chess is kind of leaned into it. Like the individual that was accused was at the U.S. championships. And like I only know about all this stuff. I don't play chess. I don't know anything about chess.
这种刺激就像……我不知道你是否听说过国际象棋的抓马（闹剧）。是的，是的。但事实上，这并不是一件很好的事情。你当然不希望有更多的作弊等等之类的事情发生。但看起来国际象棋界真的顺应了这一点。被指控的那个人甚至出现在了美国锦标赛上。我之所以知道所有这些事情，是因为我不玩国际象棋，我对国际象棋一无所知。
I mean, I know the basic rules, but I know about it because like you see something on YouTube of oh you got this now and i've watched probably now like five hours worth of like chess vlogs talking about the drama and uh and there's yeah it's unfortunate that this kind of stuff drives clicks and impressions and views and stuff it's it's probably would be better if people were more interested in just the mundane things. But well, I guess on that note, I will leave what I have to say on this. I have the next I think it's next 11 episodes of C++ Weekly fully planned out. A lot of them are going to be leaning towards clickbait. Perfect. But it is all about trying to get best practices out there more.
我是说，我知道基本规则，但我知道这些是因为你在 YouTube 上看到诸如“哦，你现在有这个了”之类的视频。我大概已经看了五个小时讨论这场闹剧的国际象棋 vlog 了。而且……是的，这种事情能带来点击量、曝光率和浏览量，真是不幸。如果大家对那些平凡的事物更感兴趣，可能会更好。不过，好吧，就冲这一点，我将结束我对此想说的话。C++ Weekly 接下来的……我想是接下来的 11 集我已经完全规划好了。其中很多都将倾向于标题党。完美。但这都是为了把最佳实践更好地推广出去。
That's the goal. Clickbait in the spirit of improving C++ code out in the world, I think, that's definitely allowed. Okay. All right. Well, let's replug because this is like probably episode three of three. I'll probably dice this up into three. So we'll replug all of Jason's, I guess. Actually, yeah, you can still go listen to the podcast a lot of that stuff is timeless especially
这就是目标。本着为了改善世界上 C++ 代码的精神去搞标题党，我认为这绝对是可以接受的。好吧。好吧，让我们再次宣传一下，因为这可能是三部曲中的第三集。我可能会把它切成三部分。所以我们会再次宣传杰森的所有内容，我想……实际上，是的，你仍然可以去听这个播客，其中的很多内容都是永不过时的，特别是……
some of the conversations with yeah a few folks it has nothing to do with topical stuff it's just about c++ best practices so yeah go listen to all 349 episodes if you already haven't uh go subscribe to jason's youtube channel buy his books if you're a corporation listening to this as corporations obviously do hire him to do training anything else you buy his books. If you're a corporation listening to this, as corporations obviously do, hire him to do training. Anything else you want to plug or things you want to say? I do want to say
与某些人的对话，这与时事无关，它只关乎 C++ 的最佳实践。所以，是的，如果还没听过，去听听全部 349 集吧。去订阅杰森的 YouTube 频道，买他的书。如果你是一个正在收听这个节目的企业——正如企业显然会做的那样——雇他去做培训吧。还有什么你想宣传的或者想说的吗？我确实想说……
that my puzzle books are actually designed to be fun, just for the record. And people have actually told me that they are fun. They're not like painful C++ puzzles. They are fun C++ puzzles.
我的解谜书其实是为了好玩而设计的，特此声明。而且人们也确实告诉我它们真的很好玩。它们不是那种痛苦的 C++ 谜题。它们是有趣的 C++ 谜题。
Yeah. Haven't you said that you're, I think it's your niece, if I recall correctly, like you had her edit them for you? She was my play tester for my first couple of books. Yeah. And she knows nothing about programming and nothing about C++. When she learned the rules, she was like, oh, this is good and got into it.
是的。你不是说过，我想如果我没记错的话，你的侄女——你让她帮你编辑的吗？她是我前几本书的游戏测试员。是的。而且她对编程一无所知，对 C++ 一无所知。当她学会了规则后，她说：“哦，这挺好，”然后就迷上了。
Yeah. I mean, that's like, that should be the, you know, on the back cover on the front cover, you know, not sure how old, just like non-c++ uh uh enjoyer of games she was 18 19 something like that 18 yeah yeah so even non-c++ folks can can enjoy them um so yeah links for all of that stuff in the show notes uh thank you so much for coming on hopefully we'll get rob on and then maybe at some point if you guys ever want to have a reunion you can come on and uh for old time's sakes. Let us know. Technically, the podcast is still there.
对。我的意思是，这应该成为……你知道的，印在封底或封面上的卖点：“不确定年龄，只是一个非 C++ 游戏爱好者”。她当时 18、19 岁左右吧？18 岁，对。所以即使是不懂 C++ 的人也能享受其中。所以，是的，所有这些东西的链接都在节目简介里。非常感谢你能来。希望我们能请到罗布，然后也许在某个时候，如果你们想举办一个重温聚会，你们可以来叙叙旧。让我们知道。严格来说，播客还在那里。
You said the same thing as the new Rustation said, is that we're retiring for now, but maybe not forever. Maybe not forever. There could be a chance. Maybe it'll even just be like a Christmas special every year or something that Rob and Jason get back together once a year to talk what happened in the last year. That could be fun. One can wish, one can hope. All right. Thanks so much, Jason. We'll do this again in the future. Thanks, Connor. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你说了和新 Rustation 相同的话，那就是我们现在要退休了，但也许不是永远。也许不是永远。还有机会。也许甚至每年只做一个圣诞特辑之类的，罗布和杰森每年聚在一起一次，谈谈过去一年发生了什么。那会很有趣。人们总可以去设想，去希望。好的。非常感谢，杰森。我们以后还会再做这个的。谢谢，康纳。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝有个美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。